[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
i was in the room when my dad died right
did he have a long prolonged health
issue yeah he had um
stroke i don't know i'm asking
i just told you well you said it like
hey [ __ ] how did you not know
no i told you no you asked me okay all
right no no no just stop
all right i hate when white dudes do
this wait whoa whoa what
what i get a lot but um i hate it when
people do this when they
when you ask me let's just stop when you
ask me a question
and i answer you accordingly mm-hmm and
then you go and then you
do some defense i apologize you're
welcome you had a stroke
right and then how long was the but this
is something i remember
okay so the the nurse goes
or the hospice nurse goes any moment now
he's gonna die what's so funny what's so
funny
[Laughter]
just the idea of just a nurse going any
moment now
i don't know how that's funny it's gonna
it's gonna happen yeah yeah are you guys
ready yes she goes
at any moment and one
[Laughter]
you know i have to be really drunk to do
it in desperation and i was a kid
drunk gay i never did it before under
the age
have you done it since you guys been
together no no
i don't know no i'm telling you no no
the last gay experience i had was
probably
16. okay okay do you have to think about
it
no i never think about it do you ever
think about it i don't think about dick
do you think about it while you're
making love no i don't think about oh
make a love durham oh tom hardy i don't
think that tom segura tom square
but i never think of like another guy
i've ever no guys
now when you're at the beach oh my god
i'm not and you're at the beach
and there's good looking people walking
around do you check out guys he does
a thousand percent no oh my god you guys
are so crazy you do
i don't check out guys what i do is this
that's all you do
look at him baby he's so cute look at
those baby babies don't do that
how do you do that's ridiculous can i
say this no
first of all would it be weird if i was
at the beach and i looked at
hot chicks and look at that ass to you i
would
either way you know i'm just saying i
just find that to be
um yeah guys who do that too much i feel
are gay disrespectful oh like over the
top
one time i met a guy who's famous and i
can't tell you who but i'll tell you
can i guess
[Laughter]
stop what we're asking right we're not
gonna after you answer this one question
this this it's not like it's not gonna
it's not a floodgate situation
we're gonna ask one thing i just need to
know what he does for a living and
that's all
i don't i don't want to know anything
else so is he a comedian he's in the
entertainment business is he a comedian
he's on camera okay podcaster
no that's what he says so i'm meeting
this guy someone we know
i mean this dude who's a well-known
person and as i'm
before i meet him like like he's down
the hall right and i'm talking to
somebody
he's like oh you're gonna he's like oh
you know so-and-so's here i'm like oh
cool
and he goes uh he's uh pretends that
he's not um
gay you know like makes makes a joke
about it and i was like okay okay like i
don't care
but he's like it's pretty funny he just
says that
i know we go okay i meet the guy
and as i meet him i'm like hey what's up
and he goes oh what'd you do last night
i was like oh you know got in here we
had dinner
and he goes oh yeah i was with this girl
last night and i go oh cool
like first of all i just met him it's
not like your buddy and you're like you
hook up last
i just met him he's like yeah i was with
this girl last night and i was like oh
cool he was like
i mean i ate her [ __ ] and uh he goes i
could
i could eat that [ __ ] all night
i was like who the [ __ ] like nobody goes
he touched it all night yeah and i was
like yeah
it was a good he was like he's like yeah
man i just love it you know i just love
doing that and i was like and so we
talked for a moment and then i
stopped talking to him and i talked to
my friend i was like that dude is
definitely
yeah wait how did you meet your wife i
know she's doing doing something
but we were friends because she had a
boyfriend asian and
you said that with why would you say at
that just to no i'm just telling the
story no but you
pulled both hands toward me like i was
disgusting i did it like disappointed i
was like
yeah yeah yeah and lived [ __ ] lived
with him oh
but i mean what kind of yeah what kind
of asian was he oh um
chinese oh they they are good husbands
they're good husbands yeah chinese men
they were together for five years i was
friends with her we would do shows like
like part of the crew you know like
would you give her [ __ ] eyes for five
years no no we were totally getting
friends
and i i was always thought she was
attracted but you're like she's you know
she's taken and then i got the
the call like one of my one of my spies
was like yeah they broke up and i was
like i'm gonna swing in there and see
what's up
how long after they broke up did you it
was like a few months
yeah i mean that's a long relationship
was there flirtation in there though
before
a little bit i mean no i i don't feel
like no
there was never like anything like it
was like a respectful thing you know
like i was always
i treated her like with respect and uh
just like another comic really
really yeah i really did but you did so
but dee dunn said you're like she's cute
yeah of course i thought she was curious
but i mean i was like
if somebody's like that person lives
with somebody you're not like
it'll work right yeah
and then so it just hit it off right
away yeah we had a couple uh
you know some funny i tried to i tried
to do an la thing
when i asked her out the first time i
called her and i was like i was at work
i remember i was working in
post-production
and i was making small talk i was like
so like do you want to uh
you know get together maybe saturday and
she was like sure i was like you want to
go on a hike because i was like a very
la yeah
yeah and she goes no
and then i just go all right i just hung
up
i was like all right later like i didn't
you had a follow-up thing
you didn't have a follow-up no recourse
okay i was like you don't want to go on
hike
dinner didn't like come to mind no i'm
kind of slow
i'd be sleeping on my bed my dad would
come home and i could hear him park his
car
and then he would open up the garage so
my garage this is the garage door
then it was my bedroom steve's bedroom
right
then a guest room and then my parents
room at the end of the hallway
you would hear the door open you could
hear him do a [ __ ] sprint
and run every night he would do that why
would he
sprint because that part of the [ __ ]
hallway
was haunted so you're spreading through
it
my brother got possessed my brother got
possessed
i got possessed once i had to go in the
swimming pool to get unpossessed okay
what what what what
my brother talking about okay what do
you mean you had to go in this swimming
pool to get unprecedented
can we call them yeah my brother was on
last week now check it out okay
and we've talked about this before we
believe
that on our side of the house we lived
on
an indian because the town was called
poway we lived on an indian burial
ground oh poway high school
yeah yeah i know some famous alums yeah
and that's called a callback all right
and that's why you're good and that's
why you're the best in the game thanks
and that's why you're great in countdown
appreciate it
all right yes so then we lived in so my
brother
right his eyes rolled back one time and
he
started convulsing and my aunt and my
uncle and my dad had to hold my brother
down
and he was convulsing right because he
they thought that he was being
possessed by native native spirits so
one day
i'm taking a nap yeah right and i can't
move my body
like something's holding me down why are
you smiling
i'm just waiting no that's [ __ ] you man
and that's why i
that's why [ __ ] you man that's why i
have a hard time andrew
he's looking he's not even [ __ ]
paying attention he's tweeting
i'm i'm reading about pauway high school
yeah yeah
so i something's holding me down right
i go i can't get up wait why did you
have an accident for that
because that's my inner voice okay okay
i wouldn't say that out loud
i can't get it yeah yeah yeah i can't
get up
right right
yeah and i didn't know what to do so i
just run right
into the laundry room outside the door
and i jump in
the winter cold swimming pool
with all my clothes off yeah on and i
get to the surface
and the possession was gone right so we
made the mistake of telling my dad this
the two incidents so for since we lived
in the house
he would run through our part of the
house i mean what did he think when you
told him the stories
because no that's in your mind yeah
that's not real
right oh no no no no there's no ghost
here
expensive house right right but then
he would park and run yeah right yeah
that's [ __ ] sabotage for sure yeah
yeah
but when i was 23 was the first time
i made love to a woman right like aid or
[ __ ]
that wasn't a prostitute okay okay
this is when i did stand i what go ahead
what is that funny to you because you
know what it's so funny that you make
that face because
you know i see photos of you sometimes
you'll post it or
christine your wife will post it
christine yeah christina and i'll i'll
see um
a young tom suguro photo and you know
oddly enough
you're a very handsome guy okay you're a
football player right and god bless you
that you were born with those genetics
all right but let me say something right
now some of us some of us weren't born
with those gifts
all right okay i got [ __ ] genetically
all right my parents both look like
mythological creatures
all right and i was gonna be born like
this my brother's [ __ ] as well all
right
now your brother's really cute very
small but cute okay
big lips big butt they just backed me up
for once okay
he is cute so anyway i never had sex
with anybody
until i was 23. so then out one night i
was at a club i was doing stand-up
right and a girl just goes yeah i'll
[ __ ] you you're gonna be basically yeah
i couldn't believe it
yeah so then after that i would be at
work and i'll
make i would like brag about it yeah but
oh man i had so much [ __ ] last night
i go to the airport and it's sebastian
monoskalko's was at the airport
tom was there i think dan cook was there
and you know we were supposed to get our
own tickets
so my manager abby juju she's jewish
she wants to save money so she always
gives me coach
always she's like honey it's it's not a
big deal there's no difference
right yeah yeah so now i remember yeah
yeah so then
these guys get first class yeah so i'm
i'm talking to them in the you know
you know yeah giggling their first class
and they all leave and i'm like now i
blush
and i'm going oh my god i gotta walk by
them
right and you know let me say something
walking by i don't know how christ felt
when he was like
you know holding the thing and yeah
throwing rocks but
it felt you know similar yeah i would
assume the only thing i regretted in
that moment
yeah was that i wasn't already better
friends with you because then i would
have enjoyed it
you know yeah did i just feel sorry for
him at that point no like i
with a comic you already like they let
you know what kind of person they are
so there's some comics who would have
given off the vibe of like
don't make this a thing yeah and you
kind of like if you can pick up on
people's
yeah you know body language and stuff
you're like all right you'd be like
but he was playing into like he was
talking about it like
i'm so embarrassed and i was like that's
awesome you should be
yeah yeah you know you're a piece of
[ __ ] go back there yeah
yeah yeah i mean that's what it was yeah
they were like booing did you boo i
think they were
booze and then you told the flight
attendant to bring you stuff
yeah go give them this pillow yeah no
you came back and threw a pillow on me
he took a first-class pillow and it goes
hey use that you know what i mean and it
was just
so embarrassing well then my mom goes
do you do surfing do what selfie
i have on my phone you want to see them
it's tragic
and she wanted a selfie with the family
no she was she did this one
you're right yeah so my dad's dad right
and my brother and she get in get it
right and she did this and i was just
like
you know what i mean and she goes it's
not working
i know because i go it's weird that you
want a selfie she go do the timer
i go what timer on your phone time time
so i did the timer so i
set it up yeah right and i had to run
around my dad's body
yeah right and then do a photo right and
we'd do it like three or four times
because it clicked
too early so it was my mid body they got
my mid body into the
she wanted this moment she wanted the
moment yeah well
in in order for them to get his pension
plan they needed to do a series of setup
shots so they did
a christmas photo they had yeah
easter photos this was awesome proof of
citizenship
i don't know yes but my mistake was i
sent the photos
immediately to the hudson's
kate and oliver hudson why because at
the time oliver and i were on a show
together
and so i just wanted to show them that
my dad died and
i know exactly that was the wrong move
yeah what do you say because kate
kate and oliver oliver goes dude
your my dad's not really dead in the
photo right and i go yeah yeah
he goes you don't send that to people he
told you yeah and and now kate's
disturbed
of course yeah and i go oh that's my bad
yeah that's
that was definitely weird but also yeah
you want to see him
well no no i really feel like yeah
that's one of the times when white
people get to go like you know they're
[ __ ]
you know they're different you know i
mean
this is probably what they do yeah yeah
yeah yeah
and then and then they're like yeah
let's not be judgmental
yeah can i just show you a photo or okay
yeah yeah god
you've seen them yes bobby yeah yeah
no but i was i was in the hospital and
in rehab for three weeks
so i spent i spent december in
in a hospital and then in a rehab
facility i remember thinking before
before this video came out oh you got
covered from the hospital
hospital yeah oh [ __ ] that's well while
you were there you got covered i got hot
covered in the hospital yeah
oh lord oh imagine that i have all that
and then the cove
yeah i remember and i thought i had oxy
withdrawals
because i was taking so much oxy at
first yeah they were just pumping of
course
are you on the pump and i'm like yeah no
they were bringing me the pills and they
were giving me dilaudid
straighten the iv and then straighten my
arm but you didn't have they didn't let
you pump it on your own
no no but they were coming on a pretty
regular rotation
feel good though the lot is harder the
dilated yes the oxys i was like
okay i guess i feel a little better like
it was never enough
you know when they were like how's your
pain now i'm like yeah still everything
still hurts
really yeah and they're like how about
now i'm like 100 percent
dilaudid you could thought it was like
it felt like what
heroin must feel like because you'd feel
warm
rush through your chest and then you
just be like
you know and then like and then they're
like hey by now i'm like i feel pretty
good now
like just good night move yeah yeah and
i would ask for it
like i guess i'm more dilated and then
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
just the wrong way